and here's where it's amazing you've got
the chiefs at minus 1800 then the ravens
at minus 1 000 again meaning you got to
bet a thousand to win 100. after that it
drops dramatically buffalo minus 200 new
england minus 190 indianapolis minus 155
tennessee minus 140 pittsburgh minus
135. those are the seven teams that are
in negative territory so what it cries
out for when you look at how packed they
are together from buffalo down to
pittsburgh from minus 200 to minus 135
who's the third best team
in the afc behind the chiefs and the
ravens i don't know that i can tell you
chris
no it's it's a good conversation it is
and it might be one of the teams that's
farther down the list that ends up being
the third best team you know you
mentioned those seven and then the next
three teams on the list are the browns
the houston texans and the los angeles
chargers where i want to say whoa watch
out for them that's a good bet you could
win some money there but i think
ultimately mike if you make me pick who
the third best team is in the afc right
now
you know i'm gonna go it's between
tennessee or buffalo i'm gonna look at
them right now and you know tennessee
they kept their team together for the
most part i know they lost jack konkan
but they drafted a right tackle at the
end of the first round and got some
insurance behind him with other guys you
know so i still look at them as a team
to be re to be reckoned with uh with the
way tannehill played in that running
game and i think that defense has gotten
better this offseason but i think
buffalo would probably be the team that
i look at to be the third best right now
that would be the leader in the
clubhouse for me
i like your point on the chargers though
they're at plus 175 there are three
teams just on the other side of the
seven that are in negative territory
where you have to wager more than you
can win where you win more than you
wager the browns plus 130
the texans at plus 150 and then the
charges at plus 175 and i kind of like
the charges plus 175 if there's going to
be seven teams in the afc postseason
field
that's three wild card spots that's you
know the three second place teams unless
a third place team gets in from one of
the divisions which is possible but not
likely i could see the chargers
finishing second in the division and
being good enough to get a wild card
berth over the second place team and say
the afc south chris i i'm with you i
wouldn't be shocked i mean yeah the
chargers you know again top five defense
last year that's only going to be better
this year with the draft pick and
kenneth murray and derwent james being
back healthy so you know i and they've
made some adjustments to their offensive
line i'm with you you know and let's not
forget a lot of the pieces are in place
this is why they were 12 and four in the
2018 season so yeah i i the the bottom
of that list there those last few teams
i mean again houston i understand they
lost the andre hopkins but there's still
some good stuff on that football team
too and deshawn watson's still one of
the best players in football with
weapons all around him so that could be
very scary and hey the team that i am
not sleeping on mike
at the cleveland browns i'm not i think
this is this is going to be a year where
they're going to be
a real player in the afc i do i just
think there's too much pressure on too
many people and too many players
especially in that organization to where
you're going to get their best shot and
i think they're going to surprise some
people this year
texans made it to the 508 had a huge
lead over the chiefs in the divisional
round that deandre hopkins trade though
caused their betting odds on any subject
to just plummet and maybe maybe they
fell too far we'll see they're going to
have to fill that position though
because hopkins clearly the best
receiver on the team i remember talking
to darius leonard the colts linebacker
after the colts beat the texans during
the season and they broke up a fourth
down play
that was thrown to deandre hopkins and
he said he's that's all they got he's
their guy we know that's where the ball
is going with the game on the line so
they're gonna have to find somebody else
who the ball is going to go to with the
game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports